hey guys welcome back to New Rockstars
it's me Mt and black panther wakanda
forever's ending is about to be spoiled
for each and every one of you right now
you have been warned because my god do
we have to talk about the bombshell the
Marvel Studios just dropped on all of us
in this post-credits scene that promises
an exciting future for the Black Panther
mantle so if you have not seen this
amazingly emotional action-packed
cinematic Masterpiece of a tribute it's
the late but forever great Chadwick
Boseman pause this video ask your mama
for like 20 30 if you want some soft
pretzels and get your silly ass to the
movie theater and go watch beautiful
black women fight some feisty fish first
and then come back here okay I'm not
gonna go anywhere it's fine you can just
pause the video and do that or you can
head on over to new rockstarsmerch.com
first to pick up our newest latest
Obsession shirt inspired by black
panther wakanda forever if you think I'm
not wearing one right now you would be
wrong because what
Panther on the back of my shirt but you
will see the officials oh Magic I love
this shirt so much and it could be yours
as well if you hit up durocks
asmerch.com right now because this is
not going to last forever everybody pick
yours up today all right so the
post-credits scene for black panther
wakanda forever picks up directly where
the movie left off with Princess Shiri
and wakanda having symbolically burned
her peanut garments like her and queen
ramonda were supposed to do at the
beginning of the movie before rude ass
Namor the Submariner interrupted one of
the last bits of mother-daughter time
that these two would ultimately have
before Queen maronda would unfortunately
join the wakandan ancestors after
selflessly sacrificing her own life to
save Riri Williams much like yinson
saved Tony Stark in a weird way well I
guess Riri has her own little yinson
with Queen ramonda but before Queen
Ramona died we see her visit Nakia at
her place in kapaicia Haiti where Queen
Ramona notes that Nakia apparently has
been serving the community there for six
years and was disappointed that Nakia
chose not to attend to Charles B funeral
and later on we learned from Nakia and
Okoye right before Neymar's attack on
wakanda that Nakia had left wakanda
right after Thanos attack in 2018 and
did not come back even after t'challa
blitzed back five years later in 2023.
however t'challa did go to see her in
Haiti and when Nakia introduces little
Toussaint to Auntie shuri she tells her
that the reason why Tucson was kept a
secret was to have Tucson be away from
the pressures of the wakandan throne
which I loved so much because that made
perfect sense for t'challa's character
after the events of the first black
panther film because t'challa was so
upset with his ancestors when he
realized just how wrong it was for
wakanda to turn their backs on the rest
of the world and rejected the cruel
actions and the cruel mentality that the
kings of the past felt like they had to
adopt to keep people of wakanda say
especially the actions of his own father
to Chaka who left his own nephew to be
by himself after he killed his nephew's
father his own brother King jobu King
t'challa knew how heavy the head that
wears the crown can be on the shoulders
of even the best men that he knew and he
didn't want his son to share that face
so keeping t'challa Jr secret from the
All-Seeing eyes of wakanda makes sense
because the pressures of a Condon
tradition might send Toussaint right
down the same path that King tuchaka
went down so I thought this was really
smart this was like t'challa learning
from the mistakes of his father and his
father's fathers and speaking of Tucson
I freaking love that Haitian name and
the fact that he's living in Haiti
because I am Haitian myself which makes
all of my Haitian Black Panther fan
fiction automatically Canon I'm sending
you all my fan fiction Kevin feige get
ready for it but I really love the name
Tucson mainly because of the
significance of the name because it
literally means All Saints two means all
in song means Saints Tucson I'm using my
Haitian powers
and I thought this was super fitting
considering that he is a prince of
wakanda a nation that honors and is
centered around all of their Saints and
leaders of the past from King bashenga
all the way down Queen Ramona may they
all rest in peace and look black panther
wakanda forever's ending left us all
wanting more but in a good way like the
odd damn also into this movie I didn't
realize I ate all my popcorn halfway
through kind of way one way to keep the
adventure going is to take matters in
your own hands and make an adventure of
your own in Magic the Gathering Arena
Magic the Gathering Arena not only
brings the vast scope of the deck
building card collecting classic to your
phone it's also got high-tech cyberpunk
stuff that feels like it would be right
at home in wakanda itself I mean I feel
like half of what's fun about the Black
Panther movies is the suit Tech well
Magic the Gathering Arena gots that too
coming this Tuesday November 15th you
can go back in time to experience the
brothers War one of the most important
conflicts in Magic the Gathering lore
you can pre-order on Magic the Gathering
Arena now to get everything you need to
play with a powerful mix new and
returning Annex classic artifacts power
stones and more it's a phenomenal entry
point to get into or back into magic all
you have to do is download the game on
mobile tablet or desktop to play and if
you're looking for a helping hand you
can learn to play or catch up on how
things matches the Gathering arena with
their official YouTube channel to get
started with magic the Gathering Arena
just click the link in the description
below download arena for free and begin
assembling your black panther inspired
deck today however I mostly believe that
the name Tucson was chosen mainly in
honor of Chadwick Boseman who himself
was a saint when he was on Earth and
even more so now that he is beyond it
and this is actually the first time in a
Mainline Marvel universe that t'challa
has ever had a child because in the
comic book 616 Universe t'challa has yet
to be a daddy however there have been
variants of childlike in different
universes that do have children like the
t'challa variant that was introduced in
the 2010 Avengers heroic age run that
was the son of both king t'challa and
queen oraro storm of the X-Men called
Azari t'challa and he was super cool
because he inherited both his mother's
Storm's meat and power to manipulate
electricity and his father t'challa's
enhanced super soldier physiology that
he got from the heart-shaped herb and
with these Powers Azari joined a team
called the next Avengers which was
comprised of the children of the
original Avengers like James Rogers the
son of Steve Rogers and Natasha Romanov
Francis Barton the next Hawkeye the son
of Mockingbird and Hawkeye torum the
daughter of Thor and Lady Sif and Henry
Pym Jr the son of Hank Pym and the WASP
but since Nakia doesn't have any powers
to control the weather that we know
about just yet that we know about I
doubt that Marvel Studios is going to
make their new t'challa anything like
Azari t'challa that seems like a
different person altogether however
there is a huge chance here that little
Tucson on the island could have
inherited the powers of the heart-shaped
herb that was coursing through his
father's veins when he was being
conceived via sex the devil's organ
grinding
don't know that means so we could
potentially be looking at a t'challa
with naturally born super strength and
durability much like Namor was for his
people making Tucson wakanda's first
mutant because he wouldn't have to take
a foreign radioactive substance like the
heart-shaped herb or the talocon plant
to get his powers he would be a
naturally born mutated person like I can
see adult t'challa specially altered DNA
having mutated the genes of his son
Tucson giving him the powers of the
panther naturally at puberty like a
mutant wood which is why he doesn't have
his powers now I mean hell now that
we're in this new Mutant phase of the
MCU I can easily see the mutant aspect
of Azari t'challa being adapted for
Tucson in some way even though we don't
actually see electricity power however
part of me does feel like this
introduction of kin t'challa's son does
fuel the fires for a potential next
Avengers team coming to the MCU
especially since we know that Avengers
King Dynasty is the next Avengers film
on the horizon I would love if sometime
during the events of Avengers Dynasty we
got to see an adult version of Tucson
fighting alongside his newly christened
black panther Aunt Sherry Through Time
Travel Shenanigans and maybe even Thor's
Daughter love from Thor 4 is on that
next Avengers team because if Marvel
Studios feels fit to introduce a new
t'challa like the way that they did at
the end of wakanda forever this very
much feels like they're setting him up
to take the Black Panther mantle down
the line and I cannot think of a better
way to do so without waiting for a
six-year-old boy to age two decades
naturally than for King The conqueror's
Assault on the timeline to involve a
future t'challa Black Panther in
Avengers King Dynasty but only time will
tell but this does make me nervous for
princess Sheree's Fate In Black Panther
3 because if this new t'challa is going
to take the mantle of Black Panther in
the MCU eventually then something might
have to happen to Auntie shuri so uh
she might be visiting her mom soon ish
but at any rate I'm so excited to have a
nutachala back in the MCU even though
it's not going to be the same as
Chadwick Bozeman it is really cool to
see that Marvel Studios chose to honor
cataclysm's Legacy and keep it intact
while also continuing the story of
anuchala in the MCU through the form of
a sun so I'm really looking forward to
seeing more of what Marvel Studios has
planned for this new baby boy that looks
and sounds like the corn kid
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertonment on Twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and really
fun Marvel theories but more importantly
you can follow new rockstars wherever we
are on the social media and guys do not
forget the most important part of this
video wow I got a panther on my shirt
which you can have on your shirt if you
go to new rockstarsbirch.com today to
pick up one of our new latest Obsession
shirts inspired by black panther wakanda
forever but again thank you guys so much
for watching this video I love you guys
so much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye bye
[Music]